a lot of Firsts for the city of North
Las Vegas this Thursday mayor Pamela
goins-brown giving her first state of
the city address covering all the new
developments on the horizon Madison
Kimbrough sat down with her tonight
about what lies ahead she joins us live
from North Las Vegas city hall
one of the biggest first for the city
being the mayor herself Pamela Goins
browned the first black mayor of North
Las Vegas she sat down with us to share
her vision for the future
we are redefining and redeveloping our
entire downtown core prepare to see a
lot of new in North Las Vegas to bring
in medical affordable housing a Michael
business component green spaces
restaurants shops and just places for
people just to gather and have a great
time with their families the city's
mayor sat down with us ahead of her
state of the city address to share some
of the plans for the city's expansion
just to see the increase in residential
communities our business sector our
Industrial Area marketing the city the
correct way so that businesses have an
interest in North Las Vegas and what we
have to offer the new mixed use
development in Downtown North Las Vegas
described to have 200 000 square feet of
retail space hopefully completed by late
next year
and take a look at this a North Central
Area command police station is being
built right now it's a huge benefit to
be able to see something like this go up
assistant police chief Michael Harris
sharing how vital this additional
station will be I want folks to know
that our our Public Safety is a top
priority and our citizens are safe here
and to show that we want to continue to
expand our Public Safety Spectrum
whether that be from a fire point of
view or police point of view
the North Central Area command police
station will be on Revere and Deer
Springs opening late this summer the
city is also going to bring its eighth
fire station that's set to break ground
this spring reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now